GIOVANNI GALLORO: Good
afternoon to everybody.
Welcome to this session where
we have Spotify sharing with us
how they use Google Cloud
Platform in their back end
infrastructure.
We have Nelson Arape, a software
engineer from Spotify, here,
so this talk will be in English.
I am Giovanni Galloro.
I am a customer engineer in
Google Cloud Italian team.
Here's the agenda.
We will start with
Nelson doing an overview
on Spotify and on their
event delivery system.
Then, I will provide an overview
of Google Cloud Platform
and its most important feature.
Then, Nelson will go on, will
go through the description
of the architecture of
the various components
of their event
delivery system and I
will help him in
describing the Google
services that are involved.
NELSON ARAPE: Hello.
It's a pleasure
for me to be here.
So before jumping
in our system, I
would like to do a introduction
of what is Spotify.
I hope some of you know
what Spotify already?
Yeah?
OK.
Most of you.
Yeah, we are a music
streaming system.
And at the beginning,
our key feature
was this huge catalog
and the feeling
that all this catalog
is on your device.
So streaming this
music really fast
was one of our key features.
And yeah, it was great, but
now, it became a commodity.
So people, yeah,
this is a potential,
how else it could be.
So to be on top of
the game, we need
to leverage that data that we
have collected about our users.
And so we are collecting these
data, creating new features,
and making available
to our users.
If you are a user of
Spotify, this is something
that we release a few weeks
back is that we show you
what you have been listening
in the previous summer
so you can remember,
yeah, this is
what's a catchy song that
was playing at that time.
Also, this is delivered
based on data.
We create a personalized
playlist for each user.
Also, Discover Weekly, this is
we present a playlist of songs
that we think you would
like, but you have not
been listening to.
So this is a great way
to discover new music.
So all this happens is
because we have the data being
generated on the clients.
Go to our event delivery system.
And then from there,
we do several stuff
like building these
recommendation engines, also
very important, we need to pay
our music creators, labels,
artists, and songwriters.
So we do AB testing
to understand
how our users use our
products and so on and so on.
So all I will say, our
evidently [INAUDIBLE]
in the start of this journey.
So basically, what we do
is we collect all this data
and make it available in
a distributed [INAUDIBLE]..
So our downstream user
could build data pipelines
that will take this data
and do crunching and vetting
these new features.
Something I have to
say, we are 140 million
monthly active users.
We are consuming 1.5 million
source events per second.
This is about 60
terabytes of data.
GIOVANNI GALLORO: OK.
So let's provide an introduction
about Google Cloud Platform.
As you probably heard this
morning, Google has some--
or many, probably--
products that
are actually used by more
than one billion of users.
And anybody of us
has the visibility
of the level of the scalability
of performance and availability
of this products.
What Google want to do
with Google Cloud platform
is to let their
enterprise customers use
the same platform,
the same technology
services, the same hardware,
network, software stack
that you heard about this
morning that Google itself use
to run its products.
Google wants to let
this platform be
a label to their
enterprise customers
so they can run their
products on this platform.
During the years, Google
developed a series
of technologies to run
its products, technologies
that became technical
papers, white papers,
starting from Google
File System and then
to MapReduce in 2004 that then
became the Hadoop open source
project and Dremel and board,
for example, that became
Kubernetes or TensorFlow.
And in Google
Cloud Platform, you
find the same
technologies productizes
as a service for customer
that you see here
divided in compute services,
database services, storage
services, machine
learning, and big data.
One thing that in
Google Cloud Platform
has been trying to do
at the maximum extent
is to provide
several components,
is to provide components
where users has only
to bring their
code and their data
or their code or their data,
and all the infrastructure,
provisioning, and
management is done by Google
by the automation
that's in the platform.
This started in 2008
with App Engine.
It's the platform as a service
where who deploys application
can deploy application
directly on the platform
with the development tools
or code deployment tools,
and then continue
with the services
like Cloud Storage, BigQuery,
and Cloud Pub/Sub that
are used by Spotify, too.
And that will be
discussed in this session.
But we know, also, that in some
transitional period in cloud
adoption and to address
some specific needs related
to specific customization, the
traditional virtual machines
infrastructure as a service
sometimes are the best option.
So this will be part of
this discussion, too,
and that this is an
area where Google
is continuing to innovate.
NELSON ARAPE: Thank
you, Giovanni.
So I will give first
a design overview.
This is our platform
in very high level.
We collect events
from the clients
and we produce those
events into Pub/Sub.
This help us to collect
data from all our data
centers we use.
We still have own brand data
centers and also Google ones.
But anyhow, we collect all
this data around the world.
We use the amazing
Google network,
and then we pull the
data from our consumers
and then make it
available in Google Cloud
Storage as a set of files.
We have a specific format that
we will talk about this later.
And yes, because we
want this event delivery
system to be a self service, we
have an automation deployment
that our developers just
configure what events they want
to send and we are able to
deploy the processor using
Google Cloud API, so we don't
have to be blocking anybody.
They just configure and
are able to deliver.
GIOVANNI GALLORO: Thank you.
In the design, Nelson showed
that there are three hexagons,
three Google Cloud
Platform components.
One of these is Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is a messaging
service that--
completely manage
a messaging service
that provide
asynchronous messaging
between independent
applications.
It basically implements
publisher subscriber
architecture where there
is a publishing application
submitting a
message into a topic
and a subscribing
application that
has subscribed to
a topic of interest
and retrieved the message
when it comes online.
Pub/Sub can act as a
buffer between application
because its message store
can hold the messages
until the subscribing
application is ready to receive
the message, and it has
a dedicated capacity
in all Google Cloud
Platform region.
It has been tested to
have a subsecond timing
in notification and in
message delivery, even when it
has been tested at one
million events per second.
And it use HTTP, so the
publishing application
could be any application
supporting HTTP GET request.
Subscribing application,
connecting two ways,
can in a pull way,
it has to support
HTTP GET requests, and in a
push mode where Pub/Sub push
messages directly
to the application,
the subscribing application,
as to expose [? WEbook ?]
supporting HTTP post request.
Another component is
Google Cloud Storage.
It's not just storage
where data stored
and a server does binary object.
It supports an unlimited
number of binary objects
with a maximum size
of five terabyte.
And it can be used, for
example, to serve web content,
because it's accessible
with HTTP protocol,
with standard protocol.
It can be used to store data
related to archival or disaster
recovery or to provide
to users access
to download access to big files.
Google uses this service,
this Google Cloud Storage,
as a back end storage for media
files, [INAUDIBLE] photos,
for attachments in Gmail, and
for all the other documents
in Drive.
It provide replication
and high availability,
so customer doesn't have to
manage high availability.
It is accessible, as I say, with
HTTP, with XML, API, JSON API,
and with the Google Cloud
Platform console itself,
or js.util command line.
It provides different
storage classes.
This difference is
SLA, multi-regional,
and regional are for data
accessed very frequently.
Multi-regional, you have data
replicated between two regions
in the same macro area--
for example, Europe,
in US, or in Asia.
In regional, you have
data replicated only
inside one region.
And Nearline is for
data that is accessed
less than one time a
month, and Codeline
is for data archival
storage, mainly,
for data that is accessed
less than once a year.
Then we have BigQuery.
BigQuery is basically
completely managed service
that provides the
users the ability
to perform queries,
analytics, reports
on huge data set with the
very first performance.
Our equivalent of
an enterprise data
warehouse with the
difference that users
are only to log data
and perform the queries.
Users doesn't have to allocate
capacity, provision server.
User doesn't have the
notion of capacity neither,
because capacity is allocated
dynamically on demand when user
perform the query based
on the amount of data
on which the query
are performed.
And it's support access via
JDBC, ODBC via BigQuery API,
command line, and an HTTP UI.
And then back to the
Spotify architecture.
NELSON ARAPE: Thank you.
So first diagram
was very high level.
This is a level deeper.
This is still the
three big area,
so we will start with
the producer side.
So as I told you before, we
produce more than 1.5 millions
of [INAUDIBLE] per second.
This is like average, because
there is a daily pattern
and we have high
tide and low tide.
So.
And this is how it looks.
We have our client-sent events.
They eventually will
reach our microservice
in our data centers.
So each of these microservice
will write the event as a log
line, as a cislog log line.
As text.
So on those holes, we
have deployed the daemon.
We call it the File Tailer
because what it does
is just that.
It tails the log
line and make sure
that that event has
been pushed successfully
to our even-driven system.
It reads line by line.
It's very dumb, doesn't
have much logic.
Send it to our next
component, event service.
And then if you get
200, it says, yes, it
was persistent successfully.
It also-- this log line
would be like the stats
so it will receive
an invalid code.
So, OK, I don't need to-- for
drive, but if it's not at 200,
this is not a invalid
code so he will
re-try to make sure the
data have been pushed
and we don't lose any data.
This is where the
events log is happening.
Here, we parse the text line.
We have a schema
definition, so we'll
make sure that these
match one of our events.
We also converted
to Avro because we
will push Avro binary from
this point until then.
And we also check these
events against wireless,
because it's easier for us
to changing in the wireless
to prevent pushing some
event than rolling out
changes to our clients to
stop producing that event.
So spending is good,
but waste is not.
This is our motto in Spotify.
So if we don't need
to send that event,
we will just say, no,
invalid, don't re-try.
So if everything is OK,
then we push this event
to Google Pub/Sub.
And we use one topic
per event type.
So this provides very
good acceleration.
We have-- not all the
events are the same.
And we have metrics related
to the specific event type.
So we like it this way.
Then, on the consumer side,
we have all those events
arriving in Pub/Sub topics.
And we create
sub-creations and then
we pull that data
using ETL processes.
I will explain further
how this ETL looks like.
But then, once it
pulls that data,
we do some touching
to that data,
for example, removing duplicate.
Our clients resend
events, and also
being a distributed
architecture,
could have duplicates
all the way.
So this is a component
that handles that.
And then makes it available
in Google Cloud Storage.
And we use a very
specific format.
This is how it looks.
We use cloud storage hash,
something called Buckets,
let's say like a
drive, a place where
I can store objects or files.
But inside this Bucket, we have
a semantic bucket of event--
sorry, date and time.
So we say, OK, this specific
date, this specific hour, we
will store in that
folder all the data that
have been happening for
this specific event.
So once we think we
consumed all the data,
we say, OK, we mark
this out as complete.
So this is how it looks in time.
We are making this
data as complete
because until that point is when
our downstream user will start
to run and consume this data.
We don't want to say, OK,
down through independencies,
start your crunching time, and
then later modify that dataset,
because then we will
need to re-trigger
our dependencies,
downstream dependencies
And then they will need to read
through their dependencies too.
So we take care
of not doing that.
We treat-- once we mark
a folder as complete,
we don't allow to
modify that data.
But because everything
could happen,
let's say we have an hour that
we already marked as complete,
but suddenly late data
arrives that hour.
This will happen
because we use heuristic
to determine when it's
time to close the hour.
So the heuristic is not
always 100% fine every time.
So what we do is that, yes,
this is already closed.
But then we will
move these few events
that arrived late to the
next hour that is still open.
So our downstream users
are aware of this.
So they will know that if,
for example, this hour three
potentially could contain events
from hour two, for example.
So--
GIOVANNI GALLORO: So
in this consumer side,
Nelson will introduce
other components that are
part of Google Cloud Platform.
One of those components
is Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL is basically
completely managing
the database of the
service offering
that provide the
application level access
to MySQL DB or Postgres DB.
Users have to configure only
the compute capacity needed,
the storage capacity needed,
if they want replication
and the Google Cloud
Platform automation
manage operating system
patching backups,
and replication between zones.
It explores basic
connection stream
that you can use, the user
can use, in their application.
Another component
of that is used
in the consumer part of the
Spotify event delivery system
Cloud DataProc.
Cloud DataProc is a
management service, again,
that provides Hadoop and Spark
jobs, Hadoop and Spark cluster.
It automates the deployment
of the cluster, the management
of the cluster, and Spark
and Hadoop jobs always
require a large amount of
data, a large number of nodes.
So in this case, the elasticity
and scalability of cloud
can happen because, for example,
you can pay the resource only
when you have a job to run.
And then you can shut down the
nodes after the job has run.
You can have the resources
immediately available.
And You don't have
to wait for a server
to be acquired, the cabling,
install it, then the software
to be configured.
And you can scale at the
maximum extent, number of nodes.
So the fact that you are
not allocating capacity
but you are using
capacity only when
you need to run the job
enables you to run it
at the maximum number of nodes
and finish the job sooner
and having the business
results quicker.
And then let's go to the
rest of the architecture.
NELSON ARAPE: Yeah.
OK.
So this is assuming of
what our ETL looks like.
And we decide to build our
ETL as three microservices,
And Consumer,
Completionist and Deduper.
So the consumers is
a very dumb process.
He pulls data from
Pub/Sub, and then it
will write that data as--
I mean, he pulls
a batch of events,
and will write this batch
as a small file in the one
intermediate Google
Cloud Storage.
So we put it there.
And then we notify
this other component,
called completionist.
I will explain
more what it does.
And when the completionist
say, OK, yes,
I persist your
notification that you
have a new file with
data, then that's
when the consumer
acknowledge Pub/Sub.
Yes, I have consumed
successfully this patch
of events.
If something happens in
these, and for some reason
we are not able, or the
completionist didn't return
or we have some problem writing
to Google Cloud Storage,
we know that because we didn't
acknowledge those events,
those events are still
safe stored in the Pub/Sub.
So by doing this,
we are making sure
that we are safely moving
the data from Pub/Sub
and make it available
as files in Google
Cloud, this intermediate
bucket in Google Cloud Storage.
So this Completionist,
the name is
because this is the
component that decides
when an hour is complete.
So for doing that, we use
Cloud SQL as a database.
So when you receive
a notification
that the consumer has used
this file for this event
at this date and
hour, so who will
store that in the database?
And this is where the heuristic
of completing the hour
is stored.
So here we use, when
was the last time
that consumer wrote a file?
How the bubble in the
Google Pub/Sub looks like?
We are able to get
a metric and say,
where is the time stamp
of all these events that
haven't been acknowledged yet?
So there, we know, yes, we
still have data on Google Cloud
Storage, so we cannot close
this hour at this moment.
So once all these
conditions have met,
the completion is then
decided to close an hour.
And then, if the--
for example, in
the producer side,
this is what could happen.
Suddenly we omit events, a
few events, for all the hours.
So consumers will put it,
and then the completion
will say, OK, no, sorry, we
are already closed this hour,
and we'll move it the next.
Then, the last component,
the Deduper, the name
is because here is when
we do the duplication.
This is a MapReduce job
that runs on DataProc.
We have a scheduled
service, it's open source,
called Sticks, that when it's
time to run, we say, please run
this, the duplication
job, every hour.
So when it's time to run,
it will trigger the job.
Then Deduper first
asks the completion,
is this hour complete?
If it is, it will
return the list of files
from the intermediate storage.
So this is the list of files I
need to read and the duplicate.
So after this
initialization, the Deduper
just has to produce the runs
and the duplication, which we--
this is written
in Apache Crunch.
And we sprung a DataProc
cluster just to run that job.
And when it's finished, we turn
down that DataProc cluster.
And yes, we make it available
on Google Cloud Storage.
So I have explained how we
produce, how we consume.
Now, the missing part is
how this gets configured.
As I told you
before, we don't want
to be a team that blocks
other developers in Spotify.
So we need to manage
these 250 event types.
And this presents
two challenges.
One is that, yes, this
is a lot of event types
that we need to make it in a
way that it can be configurable.
And the other is that event
types are not the same.
We have, for example,
one event type is--
every time a user
has played a song.
But we have other events like.
For example, a feature
we are developing
that we-- only a few beta
testers are using that feature.
So we go from hundreds
of events per second
to only a few events per minute.
So we need a way to
scale the consumption
to know, yes, for this event
type we need to pull a lot.
But for this other set,
with only a few per minute
this is enough.
GIOVANNI GALLORO: So to
address these scale needs,
what are the services
and the capabilities
that are in Google
Cloud Platform?
You can scale instances
in a vertical way,
so you can add more capacity
to a single instance,
you can do that on Google Cloud
Platform with the advantage
that you have a custom
VM types, so you
can provide to an instance
exactly the amount of CPU core
and the amount of RAM that
you need, no less, no more.
You don't have to be
bound to fix the VM side,
it's where there is a predefined
ratio between the number
of core and gigabytes of RAM.
And this is very helpful.
And during the usage, your
resource usage is monitored,
and you get from Google Cloud
Platform console suggestions.
For example, if you
are not currently
using efficiently
or your capacity,
you have a suggestion to
downsize your instance.
And you have estimate
of the building
saving that you can do.
On the other side,
if you are reaching
the peak of the
capacity you provided,
you have a suggestion to
increase the capacity assigned
to your VMs.
But vertical scalability is
often not enough, for example,
because you reach
a limit and you
are unable to scale
to provide, to serve
all these number of users,
this number of events.
So if you want to
overcome this limit,
you have to use
horizontal scaling,
you have to add instances to
multiply the resources assigned
to your service.
You do this in
Google Cloud Platform
with managed instance group,
where a set of instance
is managed as a single entity.
They are completely
equal among them,
so their configuration is
based on an instance template
where you decide
where this base image
on which the instances
have to be based on,
what is the configuration, what
is the network configuration,
the startup script, et cetera.
And then you deploy
these instances.
You can have regional
manager distance group, where
you deploy distances
across different zones
in the same region, and
you have a load balancer
spread in traffic between them,
so you have full tolerance,
you have high availability.
If one or more instance or
a complete zone goes down.
And you have out of scale too.
So you can figure auto
scaling, so instances
can be added to your
manage instance group
if your load increases, and
can be removed if your load
decrease.
And you can do that based
on different metrics--
for example, CPU usage,
or number of requests
hitting your service,
or a custom metric, too.
You can do running upgrade if
you need to upgrade your code.
You can update your
instance template
and trigger a
controller update that
will update your service
in a progressive way,
not disrupting your services.
Your user continues to work.
And you can configure
how to [INAUDIBLE]
so when your instance doesn't
respond to an alt-check
that you configure it, your
instance will be killed
and will be replaced.
NELSON ARAPE: OK.
So going back to deployment
automation, so we have our--
which events are defined
in system, defined--
we have a distributed
configured service.
And we use these--
first, of the event service
to populate the wireless,
so we are able to create those
[? R ?] nodes in this wireless.
And we have a
deployment service that
talks to Google Cloud Engine.
And then, every ETL
is a managed group,
DCE managed group with an
autoscalar policy of CPU usage.
So our consumer, the
ones we treat this way,
it's very simple because we
don't need to handle how big
or how small is the band.
We just say, OK, we're
pulling on the more back log
listening, Google in
Pub/Sub, the more CPU usage
will consume this consumer, and
then autoscale school policy
will decide, oh,
looks like we need
more VMs because the threshold
is higher than the one we set.
So we have autoscaler
deploying more VMs.
So we are pulling more data from
Pub/Sub but across many VMs.
And we decide to use also
more VMs so we don't waste
too much resources on
those few events that are
only a few events per minute.
So we have more VMs, but we
have with autoscaler, too.
For those we need
more resources,
please spend more
machines, or more VMs.
GIOVANNI GALLORO: OK.
I think we are done.
I don't know if there is
time for questions, or--
We have four minutes, right?
If there are questions.
NELSON ARAPE: Anyways,
we will be outside here,
if you want to
approach personally.
No No questions, probably.
Oh, a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Why are you
processing the message
before pushing them to
Pub/Sub, and why you're not
processing them after--
NELSON ARAPE: So--
AUDIENCE: --after trailing
them from Pub/Sub.
NELSON ARAPE: You
say why we don't
push from clients to Pub/Sub?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Something, or-- I mean, down
the interface between the two.
Because here you're doing some--
applying some logic that
could be time-consuming.
NELSON ARAPE: Yes.
There are two answers for that.
One is legacy.
The straight answer
is that before, we
used a system based
on Kafka, and I
can talk about some scars that
I have because of that system.
So we decided to
build the system,
keeping the same API in the
beginning and at the end.
Right now, we are
working on a library
to push, to public
directory from here to--
sorry, from here, we still
want to-- those services,
we want still some control.
We don't want to
push credentials
to all our microservices.
But we will keep these two
steps and publish directly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
GIOVANNI GALLORO: Thank you.
We are done.
Thank you.